안녕하세요, 제 이름은 데이비드 브라운이고 이 수업은 발음 수업입니다.
안녕하세요, 환영합니다. 잘 지내시나요?
안녕하세요, 감사합니다. 저는 잘 지내요. 선생님은요?
저는 아주 잘 지내고 있습니다. 감사합니다. 성함이 어떻게 되시죠?
제 이름은 루르데스입니다. 루르데스 란다요.
안녕하세요, 루르데스 씨. 환영합니다. 저는 브라운입니다. 어디서 오셨나요?
저는 온두라스 테구시갈파에서 왔습니다.
네, 테구시갈파요. 멋지네요. 제 아내도 테구시갈파 출신입니다.
아, 그러시군요. 좋네요.
네, 만나서 반갑습니다.
저도 만나서 반갑습니다.
이 다른 TH 소리들에 관한 수업을 선택하신 것을 확인했습니다. 괜찮으신가요?
네, 맞습니다.
네, 까다로울 수 있는 두 가지 소리가 있습니다. 무성음 TH 소리와 유성음 TH 소리가 있죠.
두 가지 모두 혀를 이빨 사이에 두는 것을 포함합니다.
하나는, 유성음은 진동이 있고 무성음은 진동이 없습니다.
언제 이것을 사용해야 하는지, 그리고 여기 이 다른 소리들을 어떻게 사용해야 하는지 기억해야 합니다.
그럼 시작하겠습니다. 질문 하나 할게요. 'think'라고 말해야 할 때 'sync'라고 하거나, 'three' 대신 'free'라고 말한 적이 있으신가요?
전에 그렇게 한 적이 있는 것 같아요.
그리고 이건 꽤 흔한 일입니다. 심지어 일부 원어민들도, 예를 들어, TH 소리 대신 F 소리를 내서 'birth day'라고 말하기도 합니다.
약간의 연습만 하면 됩니다. 혀를 어디에 둬야 하는지 알고, 어떤 소리가 나는지, 소리가 어디서 나는지 알면요.
쉽게 고칠 수 있습니다. 이 소리들의 차이를 듣고 만들어내는 법을 배울 수 있습니다.
네.
자, 여기 몇 가지 목표가 있습니다. 이것들을 읽어주셨으면 합니다.
음, 여기 이 목표들을 들어보시기 바랍니다. 그래서 우리는 이 TH 소리들을 구별할 수 있게 될 것입니다. 무성 마찰음과 유성 마찰음이 있죠.
우리는 이 다른 소리들을 위한 정확한 입 움직임 메커니즘을 설명하고 시연할 것입니다.
저는 이 소리들을 개별 단어에서 정확하게, 그리고 짧은 구절에서도 정확하게 낼 수 있게 될 것입니다. 그래서 우리는 문맥 속에서 그것들을 사용하려고 노력할 것입니다.
그리고 TH와 관련된 일반적인 철자 패턴을 인식하려고 노력할 것입니다.
그리고 기본적으로 TH를 사용할 때마다 스스로 알아채고 수정하며 연습해야 합니다.
그래서 오늘 수업은 발음을 위한 약간의 미세 조정입니다.
본인의 발음에 대해 어떻게 생각하시나요? 발음 연습이 필요하다고 느끼시나요?
네, 물론입니다.
네. 제 생각엔 이 수업은 우리 원어민들 중 일부에게도 좋은 수업인 것 같습니다. 그러니 긴장하셔도 걱정 마세요. 완전히 정상입니다.
그리고 바보같이 보이는 것을 두려워하지 마세요. 혀와 이빨로 이상한 소리를 낼 때는 꽤 우스꽝스러운 수업이거든요.
감사합니다.
이것을 개선하면 일상 대화나 직장에서 도움이 될 수 있습니다. 그런데, 루르데스 씨, 무슨 일을 하시나요? 직업이 무엇인가요?
저는 사실 정부 기관에서 일합니다.
사무실의 법무 부서에서요.
그리고 실제로 영어를 할 수 있는 사람은 몇 명 안 돼요. 그래서 그런 일이 생기면 제 도움이 필요하죠.
그리고 이런 종류의 단어들을 정확하게 발음하는 방법을 안다면 매우 유용할 거라고 생각해요, 왜냐하면 혼동되기 쉽거든요.
네, 물론입니다. 그래서 오늘 이것을 연습하고 발음을 개선할 좋은 이유가 있으시네요.
우리는 이 두 가지 다른 소리와 무성음과 유성음이 무엇을 의미하는지 이해해야 합니다. 왜냐하면, 음, 우리가 말할 때마다 진동을 느끼거나 느끼지 못할 수 있기 때문입니다.
그래서 만약 여러분이 손을 목 앞에 이렇게 대면요, 저를 위해 그렇게 해주시겠어요.
그리고 그냥 말하기 시작하세요. 무언가 말해보세요. 아마도 구절 같은 거요.
안녕하세요, 제 이름은 노아입니다. 안녕하세요. 네, 확실히 느낄 수 있어요.
그래서 진동하는 순간과 진동하지 않는 순간이 있다는 것을 알 수 있습니다.
본질적으로, 이 유성음들은 단어의 여러 부분에서 발견되는 모음 소리와 관련이 깊습니다.
이것들은 유성음입니다. 그리고 우리가 내는 소리들 중 여기서 진동하지 않는 것들은 무성음입니다.
그래서 차트에서 두 가지 다른 예시를 볼 수 있습니다, 하나는 무성음 thick입니다.
그리고 진동이 없습니다. 그래서 만약 손을 여기에 대면, 저를 위해 손을 여기에 대고, thick이라고 말해보세요,
thick, 그 경우에는 전혀 진동을 느끼지 않아야 합니다, 그렇죠?
다시 한번, thick, 진동이 없습니다. 아마도, 네, 하지만 TH에는 없죠, 그렇죠?
자, 다음 것, 부탁드립니다, 다시 한번 해보세요, 심지어 혀도 진동하죠, 그렇죠?
그래서 만약 진동한다면, 네, 위로 쭉, 이 진동과 성도가 계속 이어지고,
이것들과 함께 이 유성음을 갖게 됩니다. 그래서 TH와 여기 이 모음 소리와 함께 유성음을 갖게 됩니다.
그래서 특정 자음들은 또한 이 유성 마찰음처럼 다른 종류의 유성음과 함께 올 수도 있습니다.
그래서 이것은 think와 같은 단어들의 소리입니다, 진동이 없죠, 그렇죠?
Thank, then, back, path 그리고 three.
Thank.
자, 혀가 이빨 사이로 나오도록 하세요. 여기 이 부분을 읽어주시겠어요?
Think, think, think, think, back, three.
네, 좋습니다. 그래서 이것들은 진동하지 않는다는 것을 주목하세요.
그래서 이것들을 혼동해서, 예를 들어, think라고 말하고 싶지 않습니다, 그 소리는 dip 소리처럼 더 들립니다.
우리는 사용해서는 안 될 때 유성 마찰음을 사용하고 싶지 않고, 그 반대의 경우도 마찬가지입니다.
그래서 약간의 기억력과 약간의 진동이 필요합니다.
그래서 우리는 여기서 TH 소리를 연습합니다. 기억하세요, 거기서 윙윙거리는 소리를 느끼지 않아야 합니다.
다시 한번 해봅시다. 우리는, 그리고, 그, 그 소리를 위해, 손에 약간의 공기를 느낄 수 있습니다.
말씀해주시겠어요,
제 생각엔, 어, 끝부분이 좀.
무엇을, 어, 제 생각엔, 거기 TH 소리는 유성음이 아니에요.
미묘한 차이지만, 발음에는 중요한 차이입니다.
그래서 이것들 사이에 몇 가지 차이점을 볼 수 있습니다.
본질적으로, 그것들은 유일한 차이입니다.
두 그림 모두에서 혀가 이빨 사이에 있습니다, 어, 혀가 이빨 사이에 있죠.
하지만 유성 마찰음의 경우, 그 진동도 있습니다.
네, 그래서 제 생각엔 제가 그것을 설명했고 여러분은 이해하셨을 겁니다, 그렇죠?
이것은 이제 윙윙거리는 소리가 있는 단어들의 소리입니다.
그런 것 같아요. 연습해야 한다는 건 알아요.
그래서 이 단어들에는 윙윙거리는 소리가 있습니다. 그럼 제가 한번 말하는 것을 들어보세요.
우리는 this가 있습니다. 그래서 진동이 있죠.
This, that, then, mother, breathe, 그리고 they, 한번 해보세요.
네, 한번 보죠.
Breathe, that, then, mother, breath, they.
좋습니다. 여기 이거요. Breathe, breathe, breathe, breathe.
좋습니다. Breathe.
네? 그래서 거기 진동이 윙윙거리는 소리처럼 나야 합니다.
Breathe. 좋습니다.
훨씬 낫네요.
제 생각엔 다른 소리를 내는 것을 두려워하시는 것 같아요.
유성음이 있는 다른 소리의 예로는 S 글자 같은 것이 있습니다.
때때로 그것도 소리를 내죠, 무성음인 그 소리와는 대조적으로요.
그래서 거기 유일한 차이점입니다.